Is your desktop looking a little cluttered?
Here are a few tips to help you gain control.
First things first, if you're just moving files into documents...
...create shortcut folders on your desktop but limit the number of folders.
For example, create an "Actions" folder for items such as forms to fill out or files to upload.
Create a "Current Projects" folder for containing long-term items such as presentations for work.
Once the project is done, move it to "Archives."
Choose a clean or attractive wallpaper you wouldn't want to clutter...
...and consider putting your shortcuts elsewhere, like the menu or launch bar.
But if you're the kind of person who wants everything at your fingertips, check out Fences.
This free program lassoes your icons and puts them into little boxes that you can label.
Or try Dexpot, a program that turns your desktop into four,...
...categorized by different wallpapers of your choice,...
...so you can put your icons on whatever screen you like.
For Macs, try "Otto the Automator,"...
...the Mac's native application for setting up automated tasks.
Check it out in your "Applications" folder.
And if you like the sound of Fences, you can build your own version in Photoshop.
Choose your wallpaper, create a new layer and add boxes or lines.